[Musique]
tout commence à l'aube des temps dans un
amas de poussière des toiles errant dans
l'espace traverse un champ
électromagnétique
[Musique]
cet amas est alors flashé par les ondes
lumineuses et sa poussière jusque-là
inerte se transforment en cellules des
unités biologique vivante qui bouge et
se multiplient cet amas lourdes cellule
poursuit son voyage
et quand ils se heurtent à des corps
célestes
ils y déposent les clés de la vie
cependant si ces corps célestes ne sont
pas dotés d'au liquide et d'un climat
propice les cellules meurent
mais quand c'est à ma rencontre la terre
riche en nous et réchauffé de rayons
solaires les cellules trouvent les
conditions idéales pour se reproduire
apparaissent alors les premières formes
de plantes et d'animaux terrestres qui
au fil de trois milliards et demi
d'années s'éteignent en masse et
réapparaissent à maintes reprises
tout cela aboutissant aux plantes et aux
animaux actuels puis une espèce de
primate mute et devient l'homme un
humanoïde qui se distingue de tout être
vivant
il en va de même sur les autres planètes
car les lois fondamentales sont
identiques partout dans l'univers
ainsi quand d'autres à main lourde
cellules se heurte à d'autres planètes
fertile ils produisent un système
essentiel similaire au terrestre
comprenant également les humanoïdes
il y ajoute plusieurs espèces humanoïdes
dans l'univers dont la plus ancienne
les amis est au sommet de l'évolution
humaine
[Musique]
les amis ce que munich télépathiquement
avec tout être vivant
leur espérance de vie est millénaire et
il ne se reproduise pas sexuellement
comme dans le monde animal mais
sélectivement par clonage
leur technologie est si avancée qu'il
utilise les fréquences sonores pour
corriger les orbites des corps célestes
et des places leur image holographique
dans l'espace et dans le temps
s'interconnecter à plusieurs lieux de
l'univers
l'univers est immense ces corps célestes
voyage dans l'espace comme le font les
nuages dans le ciel une et feuilles
tombées sur les fleuves et dans cette
balade vers l'infini ils s'assemblent en
200 milliards de galaxies de toutes
formes et de toutes dimensions la plus
belle ressemble à une goutte de lait
c'est notre galaxie la voie lactée
elle est microscopique par rapport à
l'univers mais elle contient des
centaines de milliards d'étoilés et de
planètes de toutes les couleurs tournant
sur elle-même comme des billes
la voie lactée aussi est habitée par des
milliers d'espèces humanoïdes les plus
connus sont les arcs thurien des
androgynes de la planète du russe
orbitant dans la constellation du
bouvier mettre de l'énergie les arcs
thurien sont les auteurs des tops cycl
des dessins passé sur le sol des
planètes en collaboration avec les
weygand de la constellation de la lyre
les arcs thurien produisent des
corridors inter dimensionnels dont la
base est positionné sur un anneau de
saturne dans notre système solaire
saturne aussi est habité sur la plus
grande de ces planètes
vive les titans des humanoïdes pacifique
et évoluer d'autres humanoïdes
bienfaisant de la voie lactée sont les
six riant
le sirius la plus lumineuse d'une étoile
de la constellation d'orion limitrophes
du système solaire les humanoïdes de la
voie lactée ne sont pas tous
bienveillant les grands gris et les
petits gris de la constellation australe
du ridicule son cruel et sans émotion
ils patrouillent l'espace piller les
planètes habitées
d'autres pirates du cosmos sont les ânes
inaki qui ont quitté le système de
nemesis pour s'installer sur nini rue
une planète dont l'orbité elliptique
rentre et sort du système solaire tous
les 3600 angles ce qui leur permet de
débarquer sur la terre à des dates
précises mais les humanoïdes les plus
méchants de la voie lactée sont les
reptiliens de la planète
alpha draguer
il y a trois cent mille ans mus par
l'instinct de propager leurs gènes
malveillants les reptiliens affecte un
groupe dit en alerter les amis repousse
des infiltrations reptiliennes et pour
arrêter la contamination met en
quarantaine les titans infecter les
confinant sur la planète terre
[Musique]
la terre a une histoire particulière
dans le système solaire s'est formé il y
a quatre milliards d'années il n'y avait
pas de vie sur cette planète la terre
n'existait pas 500 millions d'années
plus tard une planète sort soudainement
de son ordre et tournant à l'envers
s'abat sur la plus grande planète du
système solaire
camatte dans la collision les deux
planètes se désintègre et de leurs
morceaux naissent la terre la lune et
une ceinture d'astéroïdes
[Musique]
c'est ce que les hanouna qui raconte
dessus mais rien qui transcrivent la
création de la terre dans leurs poèmes
les nouma hellich 16 informations sont
exactes
les scientifiques modernes ont élaboré à
l'ordinateur les événements cosmique qui
ont donné naissance à la terre tout
correspond à merveille
cependant tous les ânes inaki tient-il
ces informations il est incroyable que
quelqu'un puisse connaître dans les
détails
un événement cosmique qui a eu lieu il y
à 3,5 milliards d'années cet événement
semble piloter car il place la terre
dans la juste de position pour recevoir
la vie dans les meilleures délais au
tout début
la terre est recouverte d'un océan sur
lequel flotte une grande île dont la
forme et le nom change selon les airs
mais il ya 200 millions d'années la
grande île se morcelle en continent à la
dérive avec les plantes et les animaux
qu'ils hébergent il y a quatre millions
d'années un genre de primates
aujourd'hui appelée l'australopithèque
apparaît sur le continent africain
c'est un singe qui vit sur les arbres et
se nourrit de tubercule est le fruit
mais il y à 2,3 millions d'années son
volume cérébral augmente soudainement de
450 à 600 centimètres cubes le
transformant en une nouvelle créature
l'homo habilis comment cela at il été
possible
c'est un mystère un changement génétique
si forts entraînent la mort la science
et les religions ont élaboré une
multitude de théories sur cette mutation
inédite dans l'histoire de la nature
certains pensent qu'elle est due à la
consommation régulière d'un champignon
hallucinogène qui à atrophier certaines
cellules du cerveau de ces primates
laissant place à d'autres cellules qui
sont devenus plus performantes
d'autres pensent que c'est un dieu qui
est intervenu ou les amys
extraterrestres ou que c'est une
exception qui confirme la règle
[Musique]
les homo habilis se reproduise avec
succès et trois cent mille ans plus tard
ils se sont même amélioré leur capacité
crânienne augmente à huit cent cinquante
centimètres cubes et ils deviennent une
nouvelle créature l'homo erectus un tel
saut évolutif a besoin de centaines de
millions d'années pour aboutir mais les
homo erectus qui parviennent très bien
perdre les groupes walt les défenses
marche exclusivement debout et sont
prêts à devenir les hommes de la terre
la terre est bien connu par les amis qui
il y a trois son élan transporte au
groenland
les titans infecté le droit landes
à cette époque est un archipel au climat
tempéré qui se termine par une grande
île
donnant l'impression d'une étoile
filante au beau milieu de la mer quand
les titans arrive leur chef chronos pour
ne pas oublier leur planète perdu trace
sur le sol de la grande île des normes
cercle similaire aux anneaux de saturne
redessinant le ciel natal dans sa
nouvelle demeure à vrai dire chronos
fait cela pour trouver grâce aux yeux de
ré à la plus belle de ses demi soeurs à
leur fils aîné le titan atlas chronos
donne en héritage la péninsule toute
entière qui prend dès lors le nom
d'atlantide
[Musique]
lundi temps on l'arrière du crâne
allongé leur espérance de vie est
millénaire et ils sont technologiquement
avancés pour produire l'énergie motrice
la lumière et tout ce dont ils ont
besoin
ils construisent près des fleurs des
amplificateurs colossaux en forme de
pyramide capable de générer des
fréquences sonores à partir de gedo
[Musique]
atlas passe son temps à regarder les
étoiles
scrutant selon le céleste dont il est
descendu il calcule les orbites des
planètes invente l'astronomie et tout
comme son père il tombe sous le charme
d'une demi soeur la bellissime les
lyonnais ils ont 14 fils
cette femelle et cette malle les
atlantes à chacune de ses filles toutes
très belles atlas donne le nom des
étoiles de la constellation des pléiades
et à chacun de ses fils tous charmant
atlas donne en héritage une île de
l'archipel
dans le patriarche chronos moeurs atlas
et ses fils lui consacre un tank
entièrement couverts d'ivoire sur son
poids sans pinacle d'argent s'élève vers
le ciel
disparaissant dans les nuages à
l'intérieur du temple formentin unique
bloc d'or se dresse majestueuse la
statue de chronos
debout sur son charme tenant les rênes
de 15 dauphins et les représentants
atlas et les attentes
tout autour du temple d'effondrement 10
ans jean denis lac
alternant avec de délicieux jardin plein
de fleurs et de parfums
[Musique]
en explorant la terre les attenante
s'aperçoivent dans l'afrique vive les
homo erectus ces primates très
particulier alors empile curiosité il
décide d'en ramener un troupeau en
atlantique afin de les étudier les
erectus sont des humanoïdes sauvage
autret simiesque mais comprennent
beaucoup de choses ils sont six érable
que les atlantes s'attache à eux et en
font des compagnons de voyage dans leur
exploration du monde les disséminant çà
et là en europe au moyen-orient et en
asie
entre temps le transport des titans sur
la terre n'a pas échappé à l'observation
de certains humanoïde de la voie lactée
dont l'intérêt varie entre la curiosité
scientifique et le pillage la terre en
effet est une proie magnifique riche en
nous en combustibles fossiles et en
minéraux précieux
cette planète est une tentation trop
forte pour les bandits de l'espace se
déclenche alors des combats terribles
dans le ciel et sur le sol terrestre
entre les amys les anaky les reptiliens
et les grilles d'oust contre tous mais
les amena qui possède les armes les plus
puissantes
il chasse les antagonistes et
s'approprie la terre mars et la lune
[Musique]
arrivée sur la terre les hanouna qui ne
considère pas les quelques atlante comme
un danger il les laisse donc tranquille
sur leur île du nord
entouré dans l'océan immense les hanouna
qui préfèrent la mésopotamie
le roi a new établi sa base
haéri doux qui veut dire maison loin de
la maison laissant à l île son fils
héritier le commandement de la mission
terrestre et à son autre fils anne qui
le commandement des gisements de métaux
précieux en afrique dans l'actuelle
zimbabwe mais un problème grave entrave
les excavations les hanouna qui avec
théo mines refusent de travailler
ce sont des individus dur engagé comme
pirate et non pas comme mineur ils
menacent même de tuer leur chef
dans la bible hébraïque qui reprend deux
mille ans plus tard les écrits sumériens
cette émeute est décrite comme la
rébellion des anges désobéissant aux
ordres de lieux selon les écrits
sumériens namur la mer 2 1 qui donne
raison aux révoltés et trouve même une
solution elle affirme que non loin des
mines vivent des primates bon à creuser
la terre les homo erectus et qu'il
suffit de les rendre plus intelligent et
de les mettre au travail à la place des
rebelles
l île chef de la mission refuse de les
modifier génétiquement
mais comme les travaux traînent de
mauvaise grâce
il finit par accepter ainsi il y a deux
cent cinquante mille ans les médecins
hanouna qui greffent l'adn de nuire sags
les pouces d'un qui a l'adn d'une
femelle erectus et après de nombreux
essais celles-ci génèrent l'homo sapiens
l'ancêtre des hommes actuels
le volume de son cerveau double presque
par rapport à l'homo erectus passant de
850 à 1000 450 centimètres cube sa
taille atteint deux mètres et est en
produits à l'image des hanouna qui ils
développent leur attitude belliqueuse
[Musique]
l'inoffensif d'ailleurs de tubercule est
devenu un chasseur impitoyable
pourtant bien que fier et adroits les
homo sapiens ne peuvent pas rivaliser
avec les anaky qui les prennent pour des
animaux
les sapiens les moins chanceux sont
contraints à creuser dans les gisements
d'autres sont destinés aux travaux des
champs et à l'élevage et les plus
courageux ce chaton formant des tribus
de nomades sauvage
il y à cent mille ans un grand froid
frappe le nord de la terre le recouvrant
d'une calotte de glace
le groenland jeunes mais les atlantes de
sabri dont le sous-sol exploite les
courants souterrains deux chaudes et
continuent leur vie avec leurs
compagnons domestiques et les homo
erectus le grand froid ne s'étant pas
jusqu'en afrique le travail dans les
mines est en plein essor au sud du
continent
les archéologues modernes ont trouvé une
grande quantité de construction
circulaire datant d'environ 130 mille
ans
ce ne sont pas les traces d'une ancienne
civilisation mais des bassins de triage
où les homo sapiens travailler dur pour
les hanouna qui n'ayant d'autre droit
que de recevoir un road pas les sapiens
et les erectus ne sont pas les seuls aux
maux de la terre
il y a les ergaster en afrique
les fleuristes 26 en indonésie l'élu
zone n 6 dans les philippines les denizo
26 en russie les heidelbergensis en
allemagne les néandertal en europe au
moyen-orient et en asie centrale et tant
d'autres gens au moût différend entre
eux comme le sont les gorilles les
chimpanzés et les babouins où les lions
des tigres et des chats
[Musique]
qui sait à quoi ressemblait nos frères
préhistorique et ce qu'il pensait il y à
60 mille ans alors que les gens aux mots
sont tous en voie d'extinction
l'homo sapiens réalise le bon évolutif
le plus extraordinaire de l'histoire du
monde il se dote de la pensée symbolique
en extrayant des symboles manteau inédit
à tout organisme l'homo sapiens élabore
l'avenir l'infini et le transcendant ils
discutent de troc et le sentiment
s'interroge sur le fonctionnement du
monde et devient l'homme actuel notre
ancêtre à nous les hommes de la terre
nous ne savons pas si la pensée
symbolique vient de la nature ou des
laboratoires hanouna qui ou si c'est un
effet à long terme des mutations de
l'australopithèque c'est un autre
mystère inexplicable ce processus est
comparable à la vue redonner à la
veulent ou au sont rendus aux sourds et
ce n'est que l'une des capacités
humaines car il y en a d'autres encore
inconnue
[Musique]
l'évolution du cerveau dépend des
connexions entre ces neurones ce qui
laisse entrevoir des possibilités
infinies pour un homme au top de ses
capacités cognitives
mais l'homme de cette époque est encore
soumis aux halles où naquit et s'il
s'échappe il est attaqué par les fauves
les autres nomades
[Musique]
il y a quinze mille huit cents ans la
planète des hanouna qui nie bis rue se
rapproche à nouveau de la terre causant
à chaque fois des bouleversements sur la
surface terrestre cela alarme les
atlantes cachées dans le sous-sol du
groenland qui envoie alors un petit
groupe de leurs scientifiques en
exploration dans le monde afin de
comprendre ce qui se passe bientôt des
individus non humains au crâne allongé
et au sens rh négatif arrive tôt nil et
se présente à amman le roi hérault qui
règne en egypte les rois héros sont des
géants générés par un hanouna qui est
une femme native des lieux et ont pour
tâche de surveiller les peuples amon a
fait sculpter le sphinx un mégalithe
énorme en forme de lion et quand les
atlantes lui propose d'édifier des
structures plus complexes tels que des
pyramides
il est très intéressé et plus encore
quand les atlantes lui confie que les
pyramides peuvent produire des ondes
sonores de très basse fréquence capable
de pomper l'essence vitale d'un être
vivant et de la transférer à un autre
prolongeant ainsi sa vie
il y a environ 13000 ans sous la
direction des atlantes est supporté par
la technologie hanouna qui les ancêtres
des égyptiens construisent la plus
grande pyramide du monde
impossible à réaliser de nos jours
permettant ainsi à l'ancienne égypte de
débuter son rite du prolongement de la
vie en remerciement amon donne à ménès
le chef des attentes le titre nobiliaire
est héréditaire de pharaon
il y a dix mille ans la grande
glaciation sa chair la montée les eaux
englouti les petites îles et le
groënland rétréci mais se libère du
grand froid les atlantes et leur erectus
sorte alors des souterrains et
reprennent leur vie en plein air pendant
cette période exubérante les atlantes
chérissent si fort les erectus qu'il
leur implante les jeunes quittant afin
d'engendrer une lignée avec eux et milan
plus tard les descendants des atlantes
sont tous ceux moitié du temps moitié
erectus mais leur côté animal les
constamment à la tracts
si bien qu un mauvais jour le roi décide
de conquérir le monde
tom dans une action de chasse collective
il saute alors en hurlant sur leur
navire de guerre traverse d'un bon
l'océan atlantique et se lance ou brut
un abordage des coûts' européenne prêts
à détruire d'être libre mais les
nouveaux à plantes sont observées à nous
le roi des hanouna qui avertit de ces
préparatifs de guerre est pris d'une
colère terrifiant il rejoint le roi des
atlantes et lui jette sa colère au
visage toi tu t'assois sur un trône et
tu te prétends roi mais tu n'es qu'un
singe pour te punir de ton ambition je
te plongerait dans l'abyme je te le dis
moi à nous le seigneur de la terre
aveuglé par la colère à nous ordonne à
nice sa fille préférée de déclencher les
armes terribles n' est en fait un
plaisir
elle monte sur la machine de guerre et
du haut du ciel abat sans délai la plus
puissante des armes terribles sur
atlantis
c'est une catastrophe sans précédent
le soleil s'obscurcit et la lune en la
couleur du sang dans une tempête de feu
la voûte céleste s'enroule comme un
parchemin et les étoiles s'abattent sur
un tiers des terres et des eaux
au milieu de ce désastre
submergé par d'énormes vagues légumes le
sol de l'atlantique se soulèvent d'un
côté et reste suspendue l'on lève puis
il s'effondre en morceaux engloutis par
la mer avec tous ses habitants
[Musique]
on recouvre que le roi des maths lente
voulu sauver il se réfugie avec sa cour
dans une caverne scellée par des normes
black d'or et d'argent
mais tout est balayé par les flous et
aujourd'hui encore de nombreux
aventuriers cherche ce trésor
sur les côtes européennes ces
américaines une vague géante avance
cachant le ciel tu es le déluge
universel
les hommes et les animaux qui ne
réussissent pas à atteindre les
montagnes sont englouties par les eaux
et périssent noyés
le plus tragique et que ces coupes des
places la terre les bombardements de
neige contraignent la terre a tourné en
sens inverse comme la ruda pitié le
monde est sur le point de basculer
provocante un désastre total la ville
toute entière aurait disparu si angie le
fils cadet du roi à nous ne s'était pas
ému de cette hécatombe
[Musique]
enki persuade à nous de stopper ce
carnage ensemble ils crient anaïs de
s'arrêter mais aveuglé par la fureur
elle tire toujours faisant semblant de
ne rien entendre
alors enki il connaît bien les femmes
verse dans l'océan atlantique 7
milliards de bière formant un grand
miroir couleurs de bronze ness s'arrête
et comme elle ne peut pas résister à la
tentation de se regarder l s'admire dans
la bière puis si plomb et s'y abreuvent
oubliant sa colère
terre se stabilise mais le nord du monde
est une mer de boue atlantide est
engloutie par les eaux et de sa flotte
ne reste que trois navires de guerre que
les énormes vagues issus des
bombardements ont poussé sud de
l'amérique
les atlantes survivants les barques
d'alors au plus vite sur les côtes
brésiliennes et après avoir adapté leur
bateau à la navigation fluviale pénètre
le territoire s installe entre la
bolivie et le pérou at yahoo wanako au
bord du lac titicaca dans ces lieux les
atlantes recommencent leur vie donnant
origines à la civilisation sud
américaine avec son agriculture et ses
pyramides ainsi construit style d'eau
mexique
une pyramide dont le périmètre est
identique à celui de la grande pyramide
de gizeh grâce à leur savoir
les atlantes sont élus rois des reines
mais le respect c'est fragile et il
s'éteint bientôt
alors les autochtones recouvre de taire
leur lieu symbolique les piétine et les
oublis reprenant leur vie le sauvage
il y à 8600 ans comme prévu libye rue se
rapproche mais à cette époque la mission
terrestre
ayant perdu de son intérêt plusieurs
années la qui quittent la terre quant à
chaque fois le passage denis bis rue
pose de terribles tremblements de terre
cela aggrave la situation dans le nord
du continent européen
hyper bord est encore recouverte de boue
par les effets des faisans considérer de
nay territoires actuellement occupée par
les puissants aux les aux sons des
nobles hanouna qui de premier rang
inférieur à la famille royale avec
laquelle ils sont apparentées à nous
leur a donné le nord de l'europe
ils ont fondé des nations et sont
considérés comme des dieux par les
hyperboréens les hommes de leur suite
mais tout est maintenant submergées par
la boue
n'est-ce là très fiers fille du roi à
nous est une chose
elle a fondé sa ville dans la mer du
nord sur le sommet des terres qui
réunissait jadis les orcades au châtelet
elle a averti le roi à nous de
l'invasion des atlantes et elle a
personnellement détruit atlantide
pourtant les aux tons mécontent de sa
gestion des armes par dérision il
l'appelle la déesse de la guerre
de plus une grosse météorite tombe sur
l'actuelle lettonie causant une
explosion terrible et beaucoup de peur
pire encore marduk le puissant fils jean
qui arrive en hyper bord et c'est une
mauvaise nouvelle la williams a redit qu
il ya la guerre il veut remplacer à nous
au pouvoir et cherche des alliés à nous
de lui a donné la mésopotamie le
territoire le plus convoité mais marduk
veut un empire ils font de babylone
armes ses hommes aient envahi l'egypte
mais comme il est repoussé d'egypte et
même chassé de babylone il se réfugie
chez les aux qui eux aussi veulent
accéder au trône
comme prévu les propos
conspirationnistes de marduk pousse les
aux à la discorde
si bien qu'ils se divisent en deux
factions rivales
une fidèle à marduk et l'autre au roi à
nous
bientôt la guerre totale éclate entre
les peuples hyperboréens c'est la
première grande bataille l'humanité de
la finlande à la suède et jusqu'au nord
de l'allemagne
ce qui est confirmé par les archéologues
moderne qui en ont trouvé et datées des
traces la guerre se termine il y a
environ 7000 ans dans les aux fidèles à
mardyck chassent leurs adversaires hors
de la scandinavie et réunissent leurs
clans formant le peuple des proto
germain
[Musique]
quant aux hyperboréens vaincu il
s'échappe par les fleurs des par la mer
vers les îles britanniques et grecs
qu'ils colonisent formant de nouveaux
peuples tels les chars dan des étrusques
et les mycéniens
pendant cette période embryonnaire de
l'histoire du monde
naissent les premiers récits des
tournées au maire cite les guerres
hyperboréens n comme s'étant passé en
grèce alors qu'elles ont eu lieu en
estonie quelques millénaires auparavant
la bible raconte que l'exode hébraïque a
eu lieu au moyen-orient alors qu'il y a
des traces de lieux et de noms bibliques
et égyptiens au coeur de l'ancienne
europe du nord
cela mène à la confusion totale
platon site atlantide la place en face
aux colonnes d'héraclès peuvent être en
sicile ou à gibraltar
mais ces colonnes sont situées sur les
côtes de l'irlande du nord dans la
gigantesque formation volcanique de la
chaussée des géants y débouchent juste
en face de l'islande sur le sol de ce
qui reste de l'ancien groënland les
archéologues modernes ont trouvé des
traces d'un cours d'eau artificiel qui
coupe linéaire mans lille en deux
[Musique]
m
il y a environ 5000 ans comme prévu 10
bis rue rentrer à nouveau dans le
système solaire et s'approche de la
terre cette fois-ci les amena qui
partent presque tous telle une dizaine
de militaires et quelques jeunes
décident de rester parmi ces jeunes il y
à nay la fille préférée du roi à nous
ness est une vierge aux de plus haut
rang et c'est elle qui a personnellement
demandé à rester sur la terre elle a un
compte à régler avec marduk bien
qu'encore très jeunes 9 arrêts passé
glorieux
elle a fondé une ville et elle a même
détruit atlantide
les intrigues de marduk l'ont obligé à
prendre parti pour les aux vaincus
fidèle à son père à nous et elle a dû
s'enfuir en egypte près du delta du nil
avec sa cour de dieu et d'humains mais
marduk la poursuit même en défis alors
n'est-ce s'enfuit en grèce où les
autochtones l'appel athena est protégé
par à nous appeler 2
elle s'installe dans une plaine d'atik
où elle fonde sa deuxième ville les
anciens grecs appellent première athènes
la ville qu'elle a fondée dans la mer du
nord est deuxième à thème la ville
fondée en grèce
mais même en grèce athena ne trouve
aucun répit
son demi-frère apollon resté lui aussi
sur la terre s'installe à sparte non
loin d'athènes et la défi en se disant
dieu de la guerre pour athena l'heure
est au combat
heureusement pour elle les athéniens de
cette époque sont des hommes
extraordinaires farouches guerriers et
habile commerçants qui ont fait
d'athènes la plus riche des cités
grecques
cependant après la splendeur les grecs
connaissent la décadence athena est déçu
mais regardant tout elle elle retrouve
dans les légions romaines cet esprit
guerrier digne de ses ambitions alors en
véritable déesse de la guerre elle se
transporte à rome qui grâce à elle
devient maîtresse du mont
[Musique]
un autre jeune hanouna qui restait sur
la terre et y avait cousin de marduk
y'avait est trop jeune pour que lui soit
attribué une nation il veille alors avec
son écoute les demi-soeurs ash ra sur
une petite citée de la phénicie bordant
la méditerranée
mais ils en sont cassés par leur
puissant voisin
l'asnl acquis balle sauvée par marduk
qui les ramène en mésopotamie
le père de yahvé el shaddai leur donne
alors une famille dessus mais rien sur
laquelle veillée cependant y avait et à
ceyrat n'aime pas les steppes
mésopotamienne ils leur préfèrent les
côtes de la méditerranée alors dans le
but d'y retourner y avait promis à la
famille dessus mais rien la terre
heureuse de canard
là où le lait le miel coule à flots
c'est une région voisine de la phénicie
à plus de mille kilomètres et les chefs
de cette famille sont hésitants ils
craignent que leurs gens soient tués au
cours de la migration mais y avait les
rassure
montrant son arme destructrice et les
amène dans le désert pour les entraîner
au combat une génération plus tard ils
sont devenus une arme et ils écrasent
les tribus qu'il ouvre sur leurs
passages se dirige vers la terre promise
passe le jour d'un pont pierre la terre
de canaan et forme le peuple hébraïque
leur dieu et y avait lui et ash ra
peuvent s'estimer satisfaits ils sont
revenus à la méditerranée et médite même
une vengeance contre bâle
mais il découvre bientôt que la douce
cana ans l'actuel palestine est une
terre dangereuse
entouré de peuple belliqueux
les hébreux sont systématiquement pillés
et réduit en esclavage
tandis que pour y avait et achèvera le
plus grand danger vient de roms car les
romains occupe la palestine et athéna il
appelle minerve se réjouit à l'idée d'
écraser les partisans de marc doute
alors il y avait organisé une rébellion
contre les troupes romaines
il ordonne à l'archange gabriel devrait
génétiquement sur des femmes juives afin
qu'elles génèrent des guerriers
supérieur et c'est ainsi que naissent
jean baptiste et josbaig mais ils ont
contre eux
l'armé la plus puissante du monde les
romains écrase les rebelles et y'avait
disparaît à jamais
[Musique]
tel tout début de notre ère avec yahvé
disparaisse de la scène
athena et les autres dieux les
chroniques du monde cite encore des
objets volants peut-être des amis mais
ne parle plus de la présence physique
des hanouna qui sur la terre nous ne
savons pas s'ils l'ont quitté qui se
cache sur les montagnes ou s'ils sont
sur la lune sur mars
nous savons que vers l'an 600 camps ni
virus se rapproche à nouveau de la terre
un être non humains près apparaît c'est
toujours lui
l'archange gabriel et annonce à mahomet
l'existence du dieu alain
[Musique]
les hébreux se moque de mahomet commence
alors une guerre haineuse entre les
musulmans et les hébreux suivi après la
mort de mahomet d'un conflit fratricide
entre musulmans qui se poursuit de nos
jours dans le reste du monde depuis que
les hanouna qui se sont désintéressés de
la terre les rois ont pris les rênes du
pouvoir
les premiers rois étaient des hommes
améliorée par une intervention
génétiques sur leur mère et il portait
les ordres des halles où naquit
maintenant ce sont les fils des rois qui
donne les ordres
se disant descendants des dieux ces
nouveaux rois suivent la coutume hanouna
qui formant avec leurs familles une
classe privilégiée la noblesse et tout
autant que les hanouna qui ils se font
la guerre entre eux ces poules entre
frères et soeurs et considèrent les gens
du commun comme des animaux pour se
protéger des mécréants les nobles forme
d'eau sein de leur propre caste deux
autres classes privilégiées
les militaires et de clergé
les militaires utilisent les armes et le
clergé
le châtiment divin comme personne n'a
envie de mourir ou de contrarier dieu il
n'est pas difficile aux nobles de
s'enrichir par une succession impunis
d'abus le détournement de fou de meurtre
et de pillages les enfants des nobles
nest si riche qu'il grandisse habitué
aux hommages des paysans à la
bénédiction de l'église et disposant
d'énormes sommes d'argent
devenus adultes ils forment une poignée
de privilégiés qui se combattent pour le
pouvoir absolu mais qui sont tous
d'accord pour imposer la vie des gens du
commun selon leur bon vouloir
comme les descendants des nobles
dilapidé vie de richesse aux trois
classes privilégiées
wass ont ajouté une quatrième les
financiers les financiers n'ont pas de
préjugés sur les classes sociales
ils prêtent indistinctement de l'argent
aux nobles aux militaires aux prêtres et
à la plèbe se faisant ainsi toute sorte
d'ami relevable bailleurs de toutes les
révolutions et de toutes les guerres du
monde
ces nouveaux privilégié financent les
états accablés par ses guerres tout en
exigeant de ces mêmes états qui le civis
ni n'intervienne dans leurs affaires et
combine secrète en 1789 la révolution
française donne un avertissement très
fort aux privilégiés abolissant la
noblesse et calment le clergé mais le
général révolutionnaire napoléon
bonaparte se proclame empereur
catholique et tout redevient comme avant
[Musique]
au siècle suivant la donne change les
monarchies passe au statut
constitutionnel ou deviennent des
république laïque
tandis que les nobles les militaires et
le clergé perdent progressivement de
leurs prérogatives
[Musique]
il ne reste qu'une seule classe
privilégiée
les financiers dont les chefs sont
devenus plus riches que l'état le plus
riche du monde
[Musique]
quand il s'agit de faire du profit les
financiers sont prêts à tout en 1815
l'un de gamme une fortune en diffusant
un mensonge quand le salle la plus
légendaire des fake news immédiatement
informée par un pigeon voyageur de la
défaite de napoléon à waterloo
ce financier se précipite à la bourse de
londres
hurlant que napoléon a gagné la guerre
[Musique]
dans le désarroi général les entreprises
anglaises se croire miner est vendu à
petit prix leurs actions à ce financier
qui leur vend plus tard au prix courant
lorsque la défaite de napoléon est
officiellement annoncée au 21e siècle
c'est toujours une poignée de financiers
sans scrupules qui donne les ordres aux
gouvernements du monde même les
présidents les plus autoritaires ont du
mal à calmer les prétentions des groupes
financiers car ces derniers ont formé le
dip state un état profond au sein de
tous les gouvernements et dont la
richesse peut ruiner ou favoriser
n'importe quel homme ou n'importe quel
état pour leur part les financiers sont
de bonne foi
ils poursuivent les traditions des
nobles vont à la messe plusieurs fois
par jour prie pour eux mêmes et pour
leur famille et sont fortement convaincu
d'appartenir à un petit groupe et lui
que dieu a personnellement choisi
ils attendent tous ceux que les saintes
écritures ont promis l'apocalypse qui
effacera la populace et le retour du
messie qui régnera sur les bons oeufs
cependant deux mille ans au passé et le
messi n'arrive jamais
la population mondiale est maintenant de
sept milliards d'individus et les
intellectuels conteste ouvertement
l'hégémonie des financiers qui passe
alors à l'action sans attendre les
saintes écritures
tout d'abord il tente de réduire la
butte en prônant le quasi stop ou
d'essence dans le monde entier surtout
en afrique
puis ils profitent des guerres
de l'immigration des attentats des
agents infectieux qui cause une crise
économique qui ruine le commerce
détériore le rapport entre les personnes
et font baisser les naissances dans le
monde entier
en bref l'apocalypse ce temps espéré
[Musique]
les financiers se félicite sont exagérés
mais ils ont atteint leur but la
populace est immobilisé et ils ont tout
prévu sauf le hasard il arrive en fait
qu'un chef financier tombe fortuitement
victime d'un accident mortel comme il
croit à l'enfer et qu'il ne veut pas y
aller
il confesse publiquement ces crimes et
ceux de ses compagnons si bien qu'à
l'aube au suivant les gendarmes rapt aux
fortes les derniers privilégier les
renferme dans une prison et en jette la
clé débute alors une renaissance
mondiale où l'unique privilège est le
mérite internet en place la télévision
le niveau de l'éducation se lève la fois
réprise que comme une question
personnelle et la rapidité des
informations empêche la plupart des
opérations frauduleuses
peut-être l'euphorie générale at-elle
débloquer un mécanisme dans le cerveau
humain car à cette époque les connexions
entre ces neurones double et devient
d'un seul coup plus performant dans cet
état élever l'homme s'éloigne du
spirituel et découvre d'autres choses
réelles très importante
[Musique]
il découvre que l'univers est encore
compacte entièrement composé de
particules autonome et intelligente
communicants entre elles par une toile
d'araignée cosmique dans ces particules
sont inactives
elles sont invisibles les formes le vide
mais quand elle s'active elles
s'assemblent forme en la matière désigne
de l'univers les corps
[Musique]
ces corps vibre tous de la pierre à
l'animal et en étudiant ce phénomène
l'homme comprend l'importance des
fréquences sonores
[Musique]
il ré étudie alors les pyramides de
leurs fonctions il renie les anciens
textes orientaux et remarque que cette
branche de la science est ancienne comme
le temps elle affirme que le corps
humain vibre à des fréquences
différentes selon son état d'esprit et
qu'il est nécessaire de casser ces
vibrations pour le ramener à l'état
idéal le multi millénaire mantra
orientale produit un effet sonore qui
casse les fréquences du corps les
ramenant à la juste libration le bol
sacré ou sept métaux et la récitation de
l'homme de l'hindouisme sont d'autres
moyens pour obtenir les bonnes
fréquences le bouddhisme japonais
prévoit des heures de meaux a répété vie
obtenant un effet physique et mentale
super performant c'est le son de la
basse répéter jusqu'à la transe qui
oblige les gens à danser ou à s'éloigner
pour casser n'importe quoi même quelque
chose d'énorme
il suffit de le taper de façon
répétitive comme la torture chinoise de
la goutte d'eau c'est pour cela que les
officiers romain ordonnait d'arrêter la
marche cadence et sur les ponts pour ne
pas les casser
dans l'homme ces vibrations sont
produites par les nerfs et ceux du
cerveau détermine les pensées et les
actions savoir orienter ses vibrations
et leur fréquence signifie développer
l'intelligence des humains et même des
robots dans les hommes apprennent à
maîtriser les fréquences leur destin
s'améliore les rapports sociaux
deviennent faciles les sages donnent
leurs opinions sans se faire tuer et la
paix devient la normalité tout un chacun
commence à apprécier le vrai goût de la
vie le seul ennui et d'être contraint de
travailler et l'homme n'aime pas la
fatigue alors grâce à son intelligence
il invente des machines extraordinaires
des automates alimentée par la nature
capable de produire la nourriture et
tout ce qui est nécessaire à la survie
c'est l'âge d'or bienheureux ceux qui
vivent cette épopée
l'inter est un paradis où les hommes et
les femmes
r nu heureux et sans souci se consacrant
librement au jeu à la nourriture à la
paresse
et à tout ce qui leur passe dans
l'esprit la nécessité de travailler
n'existe plus et l'argent a disparu on
mange gratuitement au poste de
restauration automatisé et on habitait
et voyages sur de confortables
d'habitation volante alimenté par
l'énergie solaire
tout se déroule très bien
mais un seul siècle d'oisiveté suffit
aux hommes pour retourner à l'état
naturel et oublier la technologie à
l'abandon sans entretien
les machines de la survie ont envahi par
les plantes
et quand les moteurs s'arrêtent c'est le
désastre
l'homme cherche en vain la nourriture là
où il l'a toujours trouvée affamé il est
contraint de la chercher ailleurs
mais ne sachant plus chasser ni grimper
il est obligé de se courber vers le sol
pour arracher les tubercules réutilisant
les quatre pattes dans cette position
l'homme est redevenu un singe
[Musique]
dans l'univers infini rien ne change
la galaxie blanche comme le lait airs
tranquilles dans l'espace et sur la
terre vue d'un nombre incalculable de
plantes et d'animaux dont l'unique but
est de se nourrir et de se reproduire la
vie se serait déroulé paisiblement
s'il n'y avait eu ces 5
il y a en effet des primates qui se
distingue par l'intention spécial qu'il
porte aux forces de la nature
c'est la foudre qui attise de plus leur
curiosité
lorsqu'ils la voient s'abattre sur les
arbres les transformant en torche de feu
et il constate qu'il n'y a aucun animal
gros ou petit sur terre qu'ils ne
s'enfuient devancé flammes un soir
traqué par à vivre qui le veut pour son
dîner un de ces primates aux saisir une
branche incendié par la foule et sous le
regard admiratif de ces frais il l'a
brandi vers le faux qui s'enfuit à toute
vitesse
terrorisée
ce primate est monté sur la première
marche d'une ascension qui l'amènera à
un niveau supérieur à tout être vivant
une fois de plus et qui sait combien
d'autres fois encore l'évolution humaine
recommence d'où elle est partie du singe
dans l'univers infini
rien ne change la galaxie blanche comme
le lez aire toujours dans l'espace et la
terre héberge encore un nombre
incalculable de plantes et d'animaux
[Musique]
quant à l'odyssée de l'homme la toile
cosmique à tous le thé et tous
répertoriés
peut-être même que les particules
s'amuse avec les péripéties humaine sans
pour autant leur donner trop
d'importance
il faut le savoir pourrait particules
les femmes et les hommes ne sont rien
d'autre que les animaux ingénieux moins
cependant que les fourmis
[Musique]